[Music]
one of the important themes running
throughout ursula k le guin's novel a
wizard of earthsea
is the pride and the
humbling
of the main character sparrowhawk or ged
that is his true name
and i think this is something that many
of us can relate to
as we're reading through this
particularly if we've come from a
background
that has similar
features not about magic but about other
talents and about similar social
dynamics when it comes to
what we're prideful about and why we're
prideful and how that
how that affects our perspectives and
then
what happens to change that perspective
to
show us that that pride was misplaced
and perhaps dangerous in this case it
actually has to do
with magic and and those sorts of powers
and we'll look at that in just a moment
but it also has to do
with
social status with
feeling like you're in the in group or
out of the in group and whether or not
the things you do
really matter or not how you fit in and
where you fit in and what the things
that you do what consequences
they can have so if we look at this
character ged
he is from the very beginning
of the book revealed as somebody who has
power who has potential who has
talent for this incredibly important
thing
of magic and that's going to require
not just learning a few spells or
just using that raw talent but
channeling it shaping it understanding
it
having it formed learning how to
interact with the rest of the world and
so ged is revealed as somebody who has
this power first when his his sister's
his wife's sister the the aunt who's a
witch teaches him some of the names that
he can use to get control over natural
phenomena and then when the kargish
people
uh barbarians from the further east
invade to try to take over
the island of gant and and ged carries
out some magic that both saves his town
and essentially breaks the kargish
advance
and also exhausts him and brings them to
the attention of ogeon or ogian the mage
who then begins
teaching him and that's really where our
story of ged's pride begins with his
interactions with somebody who has
genuine power
dunny which is ged's first name uh set
up looking about him in a little while
he spoke strength and hunger came back
to him
they gave him a little to drink and eat
and he lay back again watching the
stranger with dark wondering eyes the
bronze smith said to that stranger you
are no common man
nor will this boy be a common man the
other answered the tale of his deed with
the fog has come to ray alby which is my
home i have come here to give him his
name if as they say he has not yet made
his passage into
manhood the witch whispered to the smith
brother this must surely be the mage of
ray alby ogee and the silent the one who
turned the earthquake
and so
get is already
you know unusual and now he's hearing
that
he has a destiny he has something
important he's got this this possibility
and he goes to study with ogian he's
impatient
about this
and um
ged you know is is not all that happy
about waiting to learn things to
find things out uh you know leguin uses
this term impatience
and why because he wants to be able to
do things
then um
he winds up being provoked by
others and one of the first cases in
which this takes place
is where
this this girl
is is talking with him here we go
she was a tall girl about his own age
very sallow almost white-skinned her
mother they said in the village was from
oscar or so much some other such foreign
land
again thought her very ugly but he had a
desire to please her to win her
admiration that grew on him as they
talked this desire for admiration right
she made him tell all the story of his
tricks with the mist that had defeated
the kargish warriors and she listened as
if she wondered and admired but she
spoke no praise and then she starts
asking him can you do this can you do
that can you show me this can you do
that
and eventually she
says are you afraid to do this kind of
spell
maybe you're too young
and as leguin narrates for us
that he would not endure he did not say
much but resolved he would prove
himself to her
and so he goes into the house and starts
reading from a spell book that he's not
supposed to be in so he's transgressing
and he brings something into being a
shadow by the door that ojin
has to dispel and as we find out this is
a
presentment of the shadow that is going
to come about because of his wizards
duel with jasper
now what's actually going on
well
one thing to think about here is that
gad himself
is
like so many of us
in a position of inferiority when he
goes to
rock
he is somebody coming from gantt i mean
who's ever heard of gaunt it's just like
pirates and goat herders and people like
that who live there it's not you know
famous like some of the other
islands that are seen as more refined
more civilized and so he's although he's
extremely talented he's the boy from the
styx right not from the big city not
from the places that matter and that
allows him because of this
inferiority not just in social status
but kind of felt on his own part and
exploited by others
it allows him to be taunted or goaded
into doing things
that he really shouldn't another thing
that we can say about pride in general
is that there is an excessive centering
on the self the self
in relation to others by comparison
through
status it's not just a selfishness like
greed is
or like even a certain sense lust is
right
or you might even say wrath
pride
is always involved in wanting to raise
oneself up above
others whether it be it could be in
terms of wealth it could be in terms of
property it could be in terms of beauty
or handsomeness it could be in terms of
talent it could be in terms of celebrity
it could be we could go on and on and on
interestingly pride can even take the
good things about us and transform them
into bad behavior on our part
looking for acknowledgement from others
with whom one is in rivalry that you're
just not going to get a great example of
this is
looking to to jasper on the part of ged
for
whatever it is that he's supposed to get
from him
rather than simply looking to his friend
vach
who has so much more or the the masters
that he's supposed to be studying with
there and it leads to resentment it
leads to rivalry it leads to anger it
leads to
envy and we see all of these terms
coming up within the story
part in particular
with respect to the wizards duel that is
going to take place
so there's two passages i want to
read here from
the early parts of the book
in the corridor he met jasper who since
ged's accomplishments began to be
praised about the school spoke to him in
a way that seemed more friendly but was
more scoffing
you look gloomy sparrowhawk he said now
did your juggling charms go wrong
seeking always to put himself to put on
an equal footing with jasper ged
answered the question ignoring its
ironic
tone i'm sick of juggling he said sick
of these illusion tricks fit only to
amuse idol lords in their castles and
dominions the only true magic they've
taught me yet on roke is making wear
light and some weather working the rest
is mere foolery even foolery is
dangerous at jasper in the hands of a
fool
at that gad turned as if he'd been
slapped and took a step towards jasper
but the other boy smiled as if he'd not
intended any insult nodded his head in
his stiff graceful way and went on
standing there with rage in his heart
looking after jasper jed again swore to
himself to outdo his rival and not in
some mere illusion match but in a test
of power he would prove himself and
humiliate jasper he would not let the
fellow stand there looking down at him
graceful disdainful
hateful
standing there with rage in his heart
looking after jasper
ged did not stop to think why jasper
might hate him he only knew why he hated
jasper
jasper stood alone as his rival who must
be put to shame so what do we see here
this this dialectic
he feels that the other is humiliating
him
not giving him what his pride deserves
he wants to impose that
on his rival he wants to humiliate him
and so he'll start this wizard battle
and this is what leads us to
a catastrophe
so how does this take place it's at a
festival time
and
[Music]
here we go
jasper has become a
sorcerer and ged says
what do sorcerers have that prentice is
lack
jasper says power i'll match your power
act for act you challenge me i challenge
you vetch had dropped down on the ground
and now he came between them grim of
face duels and sorcery are forbidden to
us and you well know it let this cease
both ged and and jasper stood silent for
they knew it was the law of roke and
they also knew veterans moved by love
and themselves by hate but their anger
was bulk not cooled
presently moving a little aside as if to
be heard by vetch alone jasper spoke
with his cool smile i think you'd better
remind your goat heard friend again of
the law that protects him he looks sulky
i wonder did he really think i'd accept
a challenge from him a fellow who smells
of goats apprentice who doesn't know the
first change jasper said ged what do you
know of what i know
and so they engage in the battle and
jasper god says to jasper what would you
like me to do jasper the older leg shrug
shrugged summon up a spirit from the
dead for all i care
and that is what god does
thereby letting the
beast the shadow the thing from
non-being from non-life into the world
that will then become
so central to the rest of the book
and this is indeed a catastrophe
it brings about the death of the ark
mage
there on rogue jasper actually leaves
without finishing
his his training as we find out and what
happens there is a humbling
that takes place
for ged notice that i say humbling and
not humiliation humiliation does take
place it has been taking place
humbling is something quite different it
is
learning your actual place not the place
that people are going to impose on you
but the place that you have to step into
because it really is
your place it's becoming
aware of things
outside of the self as not just being
about how they relate to yourself
but having an importance of their own
and this is indeed
what happens to get
a sign of this is the physical scarring
on his face from the claws
of the beast
scarring that
gives him a different appearance he
becomes quieter
he becomes more
responsible he also is confined to rock
and there's a question whether he will
stay on rock his entire life
or not why
well
there's there's an entire um
discussion that takes place about
whether
he can leave or not
and eventually he decides to head out
and he takes a place that's kind of low
for him as we'll look at in a moment
he also has to relearn he has to regain
his control over
magic
there's damage that's been done to
others as i mentioned the arc mage
himself has to intervene
and
dies as a result of the prog the process
this is a very important
thing that ged has to carry around with
him and he knows
that others can be harmed because
if this shadow this thing
that is hunting him pursuing him gets
hold of him
it will hollow him out from the inside
and use
his powers to do great evil throughout
the archipelago throughout earth sea
itself so there is now risk to the world
because of his foolish actions that that
resulted from his fall you know
following his pride and he bears
significant responsibility so what else
goes along with his humbling taking upon
himself
tasks that actually
fit his capacities his powers
and his role so here we come to
why he ends up
being involved with the dragons
as we're going to talk about
so
um says there there was little cause
perhaps for pride in this first majesty
of geds wizards trained on rogue went
commonly to cities or castles to serve
high lords who held them in high honor
the fishermen of lotoring in the usual
way of things would have had among them
no more than a witch or a plane sorcerer
to charm the fishing nets and sing over
new boats and cure beasts and men of
their ailments but in late years the old
dragon of pandora had spawned
and so they sent a rock begging for a
wizard to protect their folk and the
archmage had judged their fear while
founded the ark mage says there is no
comfort in this place
no fame no wealth maybe no risk will you
go
ged says i will go
and now notice what leguin says
not from obedience only
since the night on rock knoll his desire
had turned as much against fame and
display as it had once been set on them
always now he doubted his strength and
dreaded the trial of his power yet also
the talk of dragons drew with him with a
great curiosity
the chance lay bright before him and he
heartily answered i will go
so
you know this is this is a
good turning point
what are some other tasks that he takes
on
the greatest of the tasks
is to face his shadow he finds out that
he cannot run away from it and he can't
find
adequate allies who will help out with
it like the stone
instead he has to take it on and here we
get to
the possibility of pride raising itself
again towards the very end of the book
as he's pursuing
his shadow across
different islands because the shadow has
now taken on his own face and form
he runs into his old friend vetch
and vach has something very interesting
to say
as
you know they're recalling what's been
going on and what what ged has to do
so
um
here we go
vetch says now lad tell me if you can
what things have come to you and gone
from you since we last spoke two years
ago and tell me what journey you're on
since i see well you won't stay long
with us this time god told him and when
he was done vetch said sat pondering for
a long while then he said
i'll go with you god
no
i think i will
no estario this is no task or bane of
yours
i began this evil course alone
i will finish it alone i do not want any
other to suffer from it you least of all
you who tried to keep my hand from the
evil act in the very beginning estario
so get is saying listen this is my bane
that i have to address i don't want you
your island people your family getting
hurt by this you were the person who's
least you know liable to that because
you tried to keep me from doing this
stupid thing that put me
in danger and put the whole world in
danger as a result
notice what his friend vetch estario as
his true name says right after that
pride was ever your mind's master
his friend said smiling as if they
talked about a matter of small concern
to either now think
it is your quest assuredly but if the
quest fails
should there not be another there who
might bear warning to the archipelago
for the shadow would be a fearful power
then and if you defeat the thing should
there not be another who will tell of it
in the archipelago that the deed may be
known and sung i know i can be of no use
to you yet i think i should go with you
so he's saying don't be prideful
about this very task that you're taking
on because you got past your pride don't
let pride come in once again and get
heeds him get listens to him and they go
off and confront it
together together as much as they can
and that is how the story comes to a
close
with a real integration
of not only ged and his own self
but him with his friend vetch
so pride is a very important thematic in
this and it's going to show up over and
over again
in other characters in the earth sea
stories
you